The lobotomy has a tragic and torrid history, in that, in nearly four decades
approximately 40,000 lobotomies were performed. If you're interested in the
history of the lobotomy there's a lot of information available on the web. In
addition, you may be interested in a book about Walter Freeman. Who's
considered one of the most scored physicians because he performed approximately
3,500 of those 40,000 lobotomies. The name of the book is entitled "My
Lobotomy" by Howard Dully. In that book, Mr Dully explains his experience of
getting a prefrontal lobotomy from Walter Freeman. Now, we're going to post a
link from a PBS special in the instructor's note box. I want to warn you that
this video is extremely graphic because it shows actual lobotomies being
performed. Therefore, I want to warn you that it can be very upsetting,
disturbing, or disconcerting to watch. So please think carefully before you do
so.